Oh
Oh
you
in chapter 13 of his masterwork
Leviathan Thomas Hobbes is laying out
for us what he calls the natural
condition of mankind and it's pretty
grim pretty stark he is sketching out
something that is going to run
throughout the history of ideas as the
kind of place that we don't want to be
and many people are going to criticize
him for his assumptions about the state
of nature and about human conflict but
many people are also going to point out
that that this is an ever-present
possibility for human beings and so we
want to look very carefully at what
Hobbes is depicting the normal natural
state of human beings outside of society
to be so that we can follow out his
master argument and see why we would
actually want to go along with the rest
of the the remedies that he's suggesting
it in part things you have to be pretty
bad for us to say yes Hobbes you're
right we need an absolute authority a
government that we can't question to be
in place and the state of nature is
going to provide some of the backing for
that so when when Hans is talking about
the state of nature first of all he's
going to call it a state of war of all
against all and the way that he depicts
human beings is that we're naturally
prone to conflict with each other on a
number of different accounts that that
actually intensify when we put them
together and we're going to look at
those in just a minute but why else is
in a state of war of all against all
there's a couple different reasons for
that one is in the state of nature we're
all more or less on the same level and
although human beings do differ quite a
bit in our physical characteristics in
in some of our mental characteristics we
are pretty much on a level playing field
I mean I might be stronger than some
people of weaker than other people and a
lot you know I mean a lot worse shape
now than I was
I was young and and exercising all the
time so you know in a pure state of
nature I might not a survival situation
it might not not fare so well but when
it comes to our physical capacities one
human being is generally not radically
different from another and it's pretty
easy to come up with simple technology
that evens things out so if I see some
guy who's coming at me and he's got you
knows bare hands he was a big burly guy
well I get a stone and I crack his head
open or I devised a sling or I make a
spear I hate too much to do that and I
can always team up with a couple other
guys who aren't quite as strong and take
the big guy down there's a lot of other
possibilities of doing the same sort of
thing and it's really the same when it
comes to mental faculties Hobbes things
as well some people are smarter some
people are are you know not as smart but
for the most part it's a level playing
field and we can count on other people
being more or less like us so why does
that lead us to war well in a state of
nature hob says there are no moral norms
or rather the only moral norm there
there is is you can do whatever you like
and so when we've looked at the
Hobbesian treatment of the passions and
desire and action we see that we're
often driven to do things that we would
like or we're driven away from things
that we would not like that we fear and
there tend to be rather unsavory aspects
to that there's a lot of desires that we
have that were we to indulge we probably
would have a harder time looking at
ourselves in the mirror in the morning
and saying you're a decent person but
that's because decency is not something
that is is there or a concern in the
state of nature that's something that
happens in civil society within
civilization with in some sort of
functioning interpersonal societal
political including economic a set of
order and arrangement that's not
something that's available on the
their Island when we've crashed the
plane or you know where I'm Gilligan's
Island you know we've crashed the boat
so how this is going to say it's a war
of all against all and what this means
is that the life of people in that sort
of condition is not going to be an N
vehicle one it sounds great you know
people say do what you like you're on a
desert island you're strong take from
the weak but that means that anybody
else can take from you whatever you take
from them they can get from you just as
easily the week and band together and
poison you in the middle of the night
they can build a pit you fall in it
nobody's going to save you so what we're
looking at there is a life that has
these these terrible characteristics and
he's got this famous line where he says
that the life of a person in the state
of nature is solitary poor nasty brutish
and short it's actually worth dwelling
on each of these solitary why is it
solitary because you can't actually
count on anybody else to cooperate with
you or to be loyal to you including
family members you can have families in
the state of nature of course there's a
natural cycle of reproduction and
families even even can exist on their
own as sort of like little mini
communities but they're always liable to
break up it's poor why is it poor
because you can't develop anything in a
state of nature you can do simple
technology but why would you invest the
the time the labor the thought the
activity in developing anything that
somebody might take away from you easily
why make your house nice why develop you
know arts and crafts to make you know
wonderful weavings you know so you can
have clothes that fit or you know
metallurgy or why even bother doing
agriculture if some guy can just come by
kill you take your field take all your
stuff so it's going to be poor nasty he
doesn't mean nasty in the way that a lot
of people do these days or they mean
dirty necessarily or
you know nasty in some sort of sexual
way he just means that you know it's not
going to be a very nice life you're
probably going to be rather grubby a lot
of the time you're not going to have a
lot of creature comforts brutish what is
brutish me brutish means like an animal
in a certain way human nature outside of
society is not really human nature for
Thomas Hobbes it's just animal nature
and we're the most dangerous animal of
all that's something we're thinking
about worth dwelling on human beings for
Thomas Hobbes can only realize human
nature within what he's calling civil
society take them away from that or take
civil society away from them and they
descend to the level of the brutes but
they're worse than all the other animals
for the reasons we're going to see down
here sure why is life in the state of
nature short because you know think
about it there's no medicine you get
sick you get an infection you're going
to die or you know maybe you get over it
and then the next one will get you
there's no common cooperation it's hard
to get places because nobody's going to
bother building roads there's uh enemies
and potential enemies everywhere you you
can never count on anybody to help you
out that doesn't sound very good does it
well how do we end up there why should
it be a war of all against all why can't
human beings just get along with each
other here Hobbs is going to discuss
some features of human nature that I
think a lot of us would like to you know
try to put under the rug and try to
ignore we'd like to think that we're not
these kind of people and Hobbes says
well if you if you're not that kind of
person it's because something has
happened that made you very very
different from most other people or
you've developed certain habits and you
probably develop those within a civil
society he talks about three main
reasons why we get into conflict with
each other he calls these competition
diffidence or anticipation
and vanity or glory and I put these
little diagrams here to try to convey
how these these work but I do want to
read some of the passages he says from a
quality of ability arises equality of
hope in the attaining of our ends
getting what we want and therefore if
two people desire the same thing which
they both can't enjoy they become
enemies and in the weight of their end
which which is primarily
self-preservation or doing what they
want they endeavor to destroy or to
subdue one another so what we have going
on with competition is two people desire
the same thing and they both can't have
the same thing this could be sexual in
terms of mates this could be about land
this could be about you know goods like
chalk you know I want the chalk so i can
write on the chalkboard get out of here
dr. Sandler it's my turn so long is it's
a good that can't be shared in common
it's something that we can enter into
competition about and when we enter into
competition because of the kind of
animals that we are and many other
animals do this as well not even just
predators many prey creatures many
herbivores get into competition with
each other over feeding grounds over
mates over things like that but we human
beings have a much wider range of
desires so we can get into competition
and in that I want what you have or want
and I'm willing to kill you or wound you
or subdue that is make you a subject a
slave for my own desires in order to get
what it is that I want and you're
willing to do the same thing to me so
that means that we're going to have to
come into conflict and actually anybody
else who's over there watching us at the
same time we'd better make sure that
when we fight we like you know keep it
away from other people's prying eyes
because if they want what we've got
while we're fighting they might come
along and steal it or they might kill
both of us so that's one main reason for
human conflict in some theories of human
conflict want to reduce human conflicts
solely to competition to say
if we got rid of competition if we got
rid of scarcity if we had enough goods
for everybody then there'd be no problem
and we'd never get into any sort of
conflict with each other if we can find
ways to you know maybe diminish our
desires or share our goods more equally
we can deal with that Hobbs doesn't
think that's the case though why not
because we have two other reasons for
fighting with each other he says from
this diffidence of one another what does
diffidence means if we go back a little
bit he says it comes to pass at where an
invader has no more to fear than another
man single power if a person plants or
souls or builds others can be expected
to come prepared with forces united to
dispossess and deprive him not only the
fruit of his labor but also is life and
liberty and the invader is again in like
danger of another diffidence means that
we can anticipate that other people are
going to try the same thing to us so you
know those I put it here you're like me
so since I know that I'd attack you
you're going to attack me I better get
you first and so that's why you know in
other word for this is anticipation I've
got this word preemptive strike there
when you preemptively strike somebody
they haven't actually attacked you yet
but you think that they're going to
attack you you're planning or you're
anticipating that they're going to do
something to you so you strike first
before they can do it this can become a
real problem because if this person over
here is thinking that this person over
here could have the same ideas and say
man that guy over there is going to be
afraid of me so he's going to
preemptively strike so I had better do a
preemptive strike before his preemptive
strike and what can happen is to people
actually just you know wind up looking
at each other and they're like oh we
gotta fight we got it we got to you know
come to blows why because you're going
to come to blows with me how do you know
that because you're the same kind of bad
guy as I am so he says there's no way
for any man to secure himself so
reasonable as anticipation that is by
force or by wiles to master all the
persons of all men that it can so long
till you see no other power great enough
to endanger him and what does this mean
well not just you know running into
people and saying oh you're you're like
me you know I'm gonna pop you in the
face and stemmons it's more like how can
I concur everybody how can I make sure
that nobody can possibly ever oppose me
so that I can be totally sure that
nobody is ever going to present a threat
at the same time everybody else is doing
the same thing everybody else is
thinking how can I protect myself
against all these other people who are
likewise going to be trying to get my
stuff who are like why is going to be
laying traps for me so you can see that
this makes it very dangerous you have
these two together you realize that
other people are going to come into
competition with you so you know for
example if your two guys and you're both
attracted to you know the same person
you know you if you know that somebody
is going to be a rival do something to
them before they do something to you
because you know that they're going to
do something to you because of the
competition now that's pretty bad isn't
it you can see there's a lot of room for
conflict not only happening but spilling
over and escalating and getting bigger
and bigger and bigger it gets even worse
there is this other motive the hobs
calls vanity or glory it says human
beings have no pleasure in keeping
company where there's no power able to
overawe them all that is somebody to
keep order for every man looks that his
companions should value him at the same
rate that he sets upon himself and upon
any sign of contempt or undervaluing
naturally endeavors as far as he dares
to extort a greater value from this
contenders by damage and from others by
the examples what does what does all
this means a little fancy language there
because we're reading something from the
17th century it means that i want you to
value me at the same rate that I value
me even if I have a totally inflated
narcissistic sense of self-esteem I'm
want you to think that I'm the swell guy
that I am and the way that you're gonna
do this by showing me things you're
gonna you're going to treat me with
respect you're going to maybe do you
know you're going to give way to me
you're going to allow me to have the
first the first word out things and the
last word now that can lead to a kind of
competition right because not all of us
can have the first word or the last word
or even the ones in the middle but
notice what's going on here instead of
us desiring something else what we
really desire is any other person and
that other person's relationship to us
we want the other person to value us the
way that we will want to be valued and
at the same time they want us to value
them the same way that they want to be
valued this is like setting up a powder
keg because not only do we have a bunch
of you know people who have no real
realistic sense of their own self-worth
and it's you know very inflated and so
they're they're ready to take offense
even if we have realistic conceptions of
self worth it may not be possible to get
the other person to acknowledge that
because they could be a jerk right they
could be captivated by their own desires
they might not want to give it to us
because they're in competition with us
or they're thinking we might try to kill
them and then there's the random stuff
that happens Hobbs has you know some
great examples here he says in the
nature of man we find three causes of
choral competition diffidence and glory
the first makes people invade for game
okay makes sense right we're greedy we
want what the other person hands so we
invade them to get their stuff the
second for safety the third for
reputation the first use violence to
make themselves masters of other
people's persons wives children and
cattle the second to defend them again
fairly rational there but the third he
says
for trifles as a word a smile a
different opinion any other sign of
undervalue either direct in their
persons but doesn't it doesn't have to
have to be in that person it can be in
their kindred their friends their nation
their profession or their name people
can take offense and feel that they have
been slighted that they've been in some
way violated for just about any reason
whatsoever even good people can do that
and when we get to bad people they're
even more liable to that so you know
again if we think about how these fit in
together if I know that that you I'm
looking ahead with anticipation if I
know that you are a vain person that you
have an inflated sense of self esteem
that you're going to want me to listen
to your nonsense and laugh at your jokes
and if I don't you're going to get angry
at me I'd better do something to you so
that you don't harm me because I'm not
going to put up with your you're not
sets we're in the state of nature I
don't have to put up with your your
silliness so all three of these can
intersect with each other and now you
see that in the state of nature we have
a lot of situations where people are
really primed to be brought into
conflict with each other once the
conflict begins there's really no way to
bring it to an end other than one party
giving in or one party dying or one
party leaving the area because there's
no common power and no norms to settle
the account and while these drives these
basic human impulses are in place the
conflict is going to continue once you
start a conflict you also have the fact
that people start telling different
stories about who started the conflict
and why the conflict is occurring that
makes it even more intractable so the
state of nature is a real live
possibility for us when things break
down one thing I do have to say is Hobbs
says that it's not necessarily a war at
every
moment like you know fighting at every
single moment so long as these are you
know liable to break out into conflict
we're in the state of war he likens it
to weather when we say it's bad weather
it doesn't mean that it's snowing or
raining all the time but it means that
it has a propensity to do so there's
clouds in the sky when the clouds are
gone then we can say now we've got good
weather and you know so long as the
clouds are there it could be raining on
us so long as there is no common power
and no norms to govern us we are in a
state where we're armed and ready to
fight with each other